Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P We had a discussion the other day
about what I call the smoked salmon bagel
index. It's like my version of the Big Mac
or the Whopper Index where I go, okay, like
what's a smoked salmon bagel cost in different
places? And the egg man wrote in with what
is, quite frankly, not a good suggestion.
Take a listen to this. Or he called in, rather.
Speaker 5: Hey, Dave, I have a question about
the smoked salmon bagel index in western
New York where I live, you can buy the
smoked salmon cream cheese spread. It's like
cream cheese and lox spread mixed to get that pink
cream cheese. Right. And then you put that
on a bagel. It's like having smoked salmon
and cream cheese on your bagel, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. You know, I mean, listen, I
think everybody should have whatever they want. I
reject the notion and I reject it wholeheartedly.
Speaker 2: That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: Yes. That the the the pink cream cheese
that has some smoked salmon kind of blended
into it is the same as properly putting smoked
salmon on the bagel. It's just I can't. And I know
we're getting very deep into Jewish cuisine here.
It's a really tough I'm not
going to die on this hill,
but it's a tough thing for me to accept.
Speaker 5: You get one of those for like
a couple of bucks. Is that good enough for you or
do you actually need the actual smoked salmon and
the capers? All that stuff for 17 boxes? 11 bucks.
Speaker 1: Shalom, brother. Yeah. I mean, listen,
I'm not a buyer at 17 bucks for a smoked
salmon bagel, but at prices south of that,
you'll certainly find me. Find me considering it.
But no, listen, honestly, that that smoked salmon
cream cheese. It's not bad. It's not bad. It's
just a whole different thing. It's a completely
different element. And I think everybody
should be aware of that. We have a fantastic
bonus show for you today, by the way. How many
people will be mad because they are taking the
smoked salmon segment seriously? Unfortunately,
probably dozens. That's a sad it's a sad thing.
On today's bonus show Insurrectionist, Senator
Josh Hawley is introducing a measure to strip
Disney of copyright protections. These people
with their hypocrisy, they love copyright
protections. They want patent protection forever
for pharmaceuticals and all this stuff. Oh, Disney
doesn't like the don't say gay bill. Strip them
of copyright protection. Josh Hawley, horrible
person. We'll talk about that. There is a.
Speaker 2: Bill.
Speaker 1: That will help women pay to travel to
California for abortions if needed. The bill is
moving forward. We are going to talk about that.
And also after this viral video of boxer Mike
Tyson showed him punching an airline passenger. He
is not going to be charged for that. And we will
talk about why and what the different elements
of that legal decision are all on today's bonus
show. Sign up at. Join Pacman dot com. I can't
wait to see you on today's bonus show. Oh, the.
Speaker 3: Bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: If Alex Jones doesn't like it, you
can be damn sure that you probably will. You can
use the coupon code Obama to get a discount off of
your choice of membership at join pacman dotcom.
You must spell it correctly. It's like correctly,
incorrectly. Obama o b, a m and a and you'll get
a great discount. We'll see you on the bonus.